we often counterpoise these to each
other as if there are two separate
domains right there's the domain of
faith and there you have to know things
through revealed truth you know
scripture those who weren't around and
that scripture was written you know
presumably through the actual Christ
event seeing the guy spending time with
him the influence behind and then
there's reason and reason is something
purely natural you don't need faith in
all in order to make it work but what is
this this is a particular philosophical
perspective visible it's also a
particular theological perspective yeah
they may be one that a lot of people
soon and in our society sort of the
defect of starting point but if you're
really doing good philosophy or good
theology do you make a lot of
assumptions like that without spelling
them out or without arguing for them
we're seeing whether they're actually
the case what do you think is the ology
just well I happen to think this will go
from there see some head shake it what
do you do
how do you tell whether this is actually
a well worked out distinction whether
things are so cut and dry is that what
do you do I mean this is something that
has theologians all of you will have to
grapple with how many of you have
thought much about the divide between
faith and reason some are
what have you made of it you know some
people would say as soon as you start
doing theology you're on the side of
faith and you may use reason a little
bit to reason from faith but that's not
really using reason and its full extent
you buy that
some people would say that over here is
philosophy and over here is theology and
how does theology different than just
plain old religious life well in
theology you begin from faith and let
you do a little bit or maybe a lot of
reasoning but you always just begin for
faith and whenever it is huge into a
point and reason doesn't supply well
just you know just go right back to
faith and so faith becomes sort of like
a a stopgap so we're like duct tape
faith holds it all together and makes it
work but it's ultimately not the same
thing as what it is that you're trying
to to put together does that sound right
to you set that guide with your actual
practice histology and mine are cuter
and Paul bridges yeah reason of the
reasons of data yeah they talk about
nothing healthfully say that is reason
it has this ascent to a extra the
tradition or this case the gospel
Church access I think the quad stocks
done is it believes in fate as an active
book 2 inch like animal will guess which
I think it's very tough away talking
about so it's reason along with the will
of a cent an extra source authority that
isn't important Aquinas is actually
within a tradition and some system some
similar things about faith without
getting the system adequate as Aquinas
does talking about different senses of
the term papers faith that's belief in
their faith as striving towards there's
a practical aspect and ansel unpacks the
discussion about dead faith in terms of
belief just on its own without actually
having any sort of striving and doing
would be dead faith notice what he does
in that he takes so he takes a
scriptural passage or a scriptural idea
and then unpacks it here's something to
think about you can approach this on two
sides first of all reason if you
actually believe in God and you actually
believed in creation out of nothing was
reason around in any sort of human sense
before God created the universe and
human beings no right reason was around
in the sense that God is rational
actually within the Christian tradition
church fathers all the way through to
people like Aquinas God is reason itself
as a matter of fact human reason is not
totally rational this is a point that
Griffith thanks but actually makes it
his contribution that that book and our
reason is is a created reason if you if
you accept the the notion that there is
a creation you know created by
providentially ordering loving creator
that's actually going to have effects on
what you think reason is so there's not
even going to be a full agreement
between
secularists and Christian philosophers
on what reason constitutes but on this
side is scripture just a fun shot of
revealed truths that are sort of thrown
out your rationally as starting points
for us or can you think of any think of
the Canon of Scripture is there any
anything life philosophy in Scripture
yeah paul talks paul actually makes an
epistemological points about the nature
of wisdom what else there's a whole set
of Old Testament literature wisdom
literature and you know where they did
they have philosophical schools you know
like play-doh not exactly but they're
carrying out reasoning aren't there so
there is reasoning with in the end of
the faith now if we go beyond just just
scripture and then we talk about you
know tradition with us or capital T all
of that includes reasoning that's done
within the ambit of faith there's a
there's what you could call a
dialectic back and forth between reason
and faith and if you accept that sort of
understanding reason can't fully develop
unless it's brought into some sort of
positive or you might say respectful
dialogue with fish or perhaps even you
know a conflictual dialogue sometimes
even conflict can be quite good in that
sense right look at the book of Job they
hash things out that's actually a book a
philosophy too by the way they're making
philosophical arguments about the nature
of the universe about moral evil about
how things work they're trying to
convince each other on the other hand
faith is also tied in with reason what
kind of creatures you've gotta make us
if we accept you know sort of the
biblical creation what kind of creatures
did he make us just like the dogs
crawling things you make is it any
different than that
yeah it's a big one that's a difference
that transforms everything I was just
reading this is sort of the side i was
just reading comments of Alexandria's
exhortation to the heathen last week and
I'm a collector of passages about what
it means to be created in the image of
God that's one of the things that I'm
interested in this philosopher and these
passages how do they interpret them what
does the qantas say well god is rational
and more rational that's how were
created in the image of God Rene
Descartes later in modern philosophy God
has infinite will we have infinite will
that's how we're created Clement
actually says he talks about music and
he says that I can't remember exactly
that the exact phrase it says that man
is the image of God human beings created
the image of God were created to be sort
of like musical instruments it's God
Himself engages in harmony and engages
in music beautiful way to think about it
do any other animals appreciate music
and we know I'm in snakes and you know
the snake charmer he's actually just
going back and forth the snake is
bobbing back for the snake doesn't
appreciate how many of you have dogs or
kids the dogs go back and forth the
music maybe
I mean that yeah they may be leading
yeah then they might dislike certain
kinds of music if it's waiting too loud
if you plug them too close to their ears
but but they don't have that that's sort
of grounding we as human beings are
different and reason is is part of what
we are it's how we get to know
everything again if you accept a
Christian view on things how is reason
not going to be tied in with faith so
that this is all just background for the
geez these debates now I'm going to make
a transition and talk about some actual
positions and people to put on the
possibility of Christian philosophy and
the connection between theology and
philosophy that were possible the other
people called rationalist of France and
here in America we would probably just
call them secularists and this is a very
broad stance it takes a lot of different
forms not everybody adopted the exact
same position as millbrae and Liam
brunschwig did in the debates but you
can see similar things being said today
right here said there can't be any
Christian philosophy and why not he's
assuming a very rigid distinction
between faith and reason he says well
what would Christian philosophy be there
could only be two possibilities either
it could be a philosophy that's approved
by some sort of he calls it a
Magisterium because again he's making
encounter friends right the Magisterium
and the Catholic Church is sort of the
ultimate arbiter when there's debates
about you know is this part of the face
is not part of the faith he chooses that
term but he points up in every religious
community if it's going to remain
coherent has some sort of body who
decides you know somebody actually lays
down the law and so there would be some
philosophical positions that would be
acceptable in other ones that wouldn't
but would this be philosophy anymore
if philosophy is subject to some outside
influence like that well then reason is
no longer what we call autonomous that
means it's no longer getting to to
decide for itself really what you're
just doing that is theology you're not
doing philosophy radians so that doesn't
work this Christian philosophy so he
says well what else could we find any
cases where Christianity has made some
vital contribution to the development of
philosophy or ever think about more
broadly to human thought at its greatest
or was there really something else going
and so right here looks at a lot of
different examples and he says well what
about the church bombs well all they're
really doing is warmed over the plate
beautiful times and I kind of mixing in
some Christian imagery with couple
Thomas Aquinas Thomas Aquinas is just
doing the same thing there so there's
the philosophy part of thomas aquinas
we've the aristotle and then there's the
christian part and there he's just doing
theology and that's not interesting the
philosophy part is just aristotle with
some extra faiths thrown in what about a
Christian philosophers in the 17th
century like to cart well you know how
many of you rent a car anytime committee
should read oh you should read the
meditations
because he has founder of modern
philosophy is sort of the founder of
modern world community we live this view
that human reason by itself taking faith
out of the mixture can solve everything
if you just purify reason get rid of all
your prejudices get rid of all your
assumptions you could find some starting
points and then from those you could
find out everything and fix everything
that was des cartes project that was the
project that carried through through the
enlight but they carts clearly not doing
Christian philosophy done because the
Christian stuff in Descartes is just
sort of window dressing he doesn't
actually believe in anything